- C'est maintenant officiel :
après avoir remporté laonononone
Smith entame aujourd'hui son
mandat comme première ministre
de l'Alberta. Un mandat qui sera
qu'elle souhaite établir
dès le départ.
Au-delà des principes, Danieller
les mêmes idées autonomistes.
Tout comme son prédécesseur
Jason Kenney, la nouvelle
première ministrnsnsnsnsnsnsnsns
Affaires intergouvernementales.
jjjà, des confrontations
se préparent.
Danielle Smith veut de nouveauvx
la taxe sur le carbone, même si
la Cour suprême a déjà tranché
en faveur d'Ottawa.
La nouvelle première ministre bt
ongles contre Ottawa pour faire
respecter les juridictions
provinciales. Mais dès
expliquer une volte-face
important à propos de son projet
de loi sur la souveraineté.
Plus question de ne pas
reconnaître les jugements
de la Cour suprême comme
il y a quelques semaines.
Même avec ecececul, l'opposition
continue d'attaquer sans relâche
la loi sur la souveraineténéo-nt
maintenant à tous les élus
conservateurs de s'y opposer
pour des raisons économiques.
- Non, ça plait pas
à tout le monde.
les déchirements internes, pour
les ererervateurs albertains,
les défis sont nombreux.
- C'est clair que c'est l'unité
- Danielle Smith doit d'abord
rallier derrièree e e tous
les conservateurs, mais
la confrontation qu'elle cherche
tant aeueueueueueueueueueueueuet
fédéral, pourtant, aucun intérêt
a a ajouter de l'huile sur le ,
observe cet expert.
FRÉDÉRIC BOILY, politologue,
- On peut gesticuler du côté
de l'Alberta, mais le ererer
juridique de la loi sur
la souveraineté pourrait
plus symbolique qu'efficace.
- Pour Danielle Smith,
le contre-la-montre commence dès
prévues le printemps prochain,
elle devapapapidement appliquer
ses réformes, mais surtout
Albertains, eux qui ont jugé
sévérement la performance
des conservateurs au
des deux dernières années.
Ici Mathieu Gohier,
Radio-Canada, Edmonton.